[Musique]
oubliez le masque ou encore le gel
hydroalcoolique face au co vie 19
le japon a trouvé une autre solution de
toutes les sources chaudes que l'on
trouve au japon kusatsu a depuis
longtemps des propriétés médicinales
efficace ces sources permettent
l'inactivation du coronavirus on
aimerait utiliser cette source et ses
propriétés pour rebâtir notre ville ses
sources chaudes se trouve dans la région
de guelma sur l'île de honshu la plus
grande de l'archipel
la cité thermale a fait étudier l'eau
l'université de la région a alors fait
une découverte étonnante
nous avons demandé à l'université gunma
de faire des recherches
d'après les résultats le coronavirus
perd de sa capacité infectieuses et
devient inactif à hauteur de 97 5%
si vous utilisez l'eau pendant 10
secondes 80 18,5 pour cent pendant 30
secondes et 99,12 % pendant une minute
résultat de nombreux japonais se
pressent désormais aux fontaines j'ai
entendu dire que la source de kusatsu et
efficace contre le couronne à virus lot
de kusatsu et très acide
elle peut soigner les pieds des athlètes
ou les maladies de peau donc j'espère
que l'eau chaude fera également
disparaître le virus j'ai entendu dire
que la science de kusatsu rendez le
coronavirus inefficace donc je viens en
profiter ne pas pouvoir se déplacer
c'est mauvais pour l'économie
j'espère aider en venant ici et pouvoir
en profiter
cette ruée vers l'eau illustre aussi la
méfiance des japonais envers les vaccins
dans un sondage ipsos réalisé en
décembre pour le forum économique
mondial
seuls 60% des interrogés étaient prêts à
recevoir la fameuse piqûre
à cinq mois des jeux olympiques de tokyo
l'état d'urgence a été levé dans six
départements de l'archipel et le rythme
des infections diminue le japon pays
relativement peu touchée par le cos vide
a enregistré sept mille 800 décès depuis
janvier alors que la campagne de
vaccination n'a commencé que depuis une
semaine